bonjour marc charrier bonjour philomène
mario paul donc on en reparle situation
quasi désespérée dix médecins sans
frontières ville assiégée qu'est ce
qu'elle représente dans la stratégie
russe elle représente beaucoup mario
paul et c'est pour ça que tout le monde
regarde cette ville portuaire avec une
attention particulière au temps peut
avoir une hésitation sur les gains que
veut obtenir j'admire poutine dans
d'autres endroits de l'ukraine autant
marioupol et sur la mer d'azov ça fait
partie de la ja les dires de la partie
qu'il veut prendre et qui lui permettra
ensuite d'avoir des manoeuvres
militaires navales comme il le souhaite
d'avoir une cohérence territoriale et
puis ça fait partie des villes qu'ils
considèrent comme faisant partie de
cette zone russophones et quelque part
c'est peut-être aussi une des villes qui
pour lui est assez emblématique et sur
lequel il ne veut pas avoir d'erreur ni
avoir à la laisser on sait pas
évidemment ce que l'avenir nous
réservera mais en attendant du coup on
voit qu'il est en train de traiter cette
ville comme il traite les villes à la
russe quand il veut vraiment les
conquérir c'est à dire avec un système
d'encerclement qui fait que ça asphyxie
complètement la vie mais c'est pour ça
que on parle de danger humanitaire pour
la population parce que du coup il n'y a
pas de quoi se chauffer il n'y a pas de
quoi s'éclairait n'y a pas de quoi
s'alimenter
si on peut éviter d'avoir de l'eau enfin
voyez c à c comme les anciens j'allais
dire siège que l'on faisait dans le
temps et ensuite avec des bombardements
intensifs jusqu'à ce que les troupes
russes puissent rentrer à l'intérieur et
les tentatives de couloirs humanitaires
jusqu'ici n'ont pas fonctionné les
tentatives de couloirs humanitaires
c'est compliqué parce que pour les
civils ça veut dire plusieurs choses
d'abord il faut que vous acceptiez de
partir de la ville ce qui n'est jamais
facile parce que ça veut dire dans ces
cas là que vous laisser d'autres
derrière vous alors vous pouvez être
dans des situations de délicatesse qui
font que vous prenez des enfants vous
avez des personnes âgées ou alors que
vous acceptez de ne pas avoir le courage
mais encore faut-il le reconnaître puis
une fois que vous avez franchi le
couloir il faut qu on ne vous tire pas
dessus du côté de la partie adverse mais
il faut on l'avait vu à sarajevo qu on
ne vous tire pas dessus non plus depuis
elle avive que vous quittez parce que
souvent les personnes qui sont en colère
quand elle voit des civils fuir mais
c'est avec nos âmes et charrier